qualche giorno fa io e il mio compagno
abbiamo iniziato a parlare di una cosa
che non mi aspettavo
a pensare a quale sarebbe stato il
momento più giusto ho corso per i nostri
bambini i bambini fanno cose strane a
molte altre cose a molte altre
percezioni una su tutte il tempo venendo
qua ho letto un detto un modo di dire
non so come definirlo che non avevo mai
letto forse fino adesso ti dice quando i
bambini sono piccoli i giorni sono
lunghissimi gli anni sono brevi
forse è vero mi sono resa conto del
momento in cui si è passato dal dire ma
sarà il suo calcetto al parlare di
quando mandarli a scuola il mio compagno
ha certo punto ha detto beh forse li
dovremo andare prima a scuola dovremo
far far loro la primina e io mentre lui
parlava di ceo
ma arrivava a questo discorso ma non lo
capivo davvero guardavo il mio bambino
di cuba la primina mandarlo a scuola
prima e gli ho chiesto un certo punto ma
perché lo dovremmo mandare prima e il
mio compagno mi fa è perché così finisce
prima e avanti allora io gli ho chiesto
ma avanti rispetto a cosa
e lui non ha saputo rispondere sappiamo
benissimo tutti quanti che occorre fare
di fretta arrivare effettivamente prima
ed è così un po dappertutto nel mondo
dell'editoria c'è questa cosa che
nessuno dice chiaramente ma che in
realtà tutti sanno nessuno ha il
coraggio davvero di dirla proprio come
la soffrire io però sotto sotto viene
confidata e che sostanzialmente fra la
pubblicazione del primo libro e la
pubblicazione del secondo libro non
possono passare più di due anni oltre i
due anni c'è un buco nero che non ti
riporta neanche alla condizione di chi
ancora non ha pubblicato proprio tifa sa
cosa succede una cosa talmente non dico
però sparisce dal panorama editoriale
italiano
quello che invece dicono più facilmente
che scrive il secondo libro è molto più
difficile rispetto a scrivere il primo
perché ci sono molte aspettative il
primo lo scrivi augurandoti che qualcuno
lo lega ma non pensi che davvero
qualcuno leggerà il secondo sai che
qualcuno leggerà sai anche poco tempo
vorresti comunque assecondare in un
certo qual senso le aspettative di chi
ha letto e apprezzato il primo ma
vorresti anche trovarti lettori nuovi
io ricordo che tuttora passo diverso
tempo a spiare dei libreria cercare di
capire la gente davanti ai libri cosa
cerca o quando avevo la fortuna di
vedere magari qualcuno e spiaggia che
leggeva il mio libro lo guardavo e
diceva chissà dove perché non gira la
pagina si richiudeva dicevo dio si è
annoiato perché quindi cerchi un po di
di assecondare un altra cosa che dicono
proposito dei libri è che si chiede allo
scrittore quanto tempo ha scritta ha
impiegato per scrivere il suo primo
libro tira tutta la vita
ed è vero il primo libro sostanzialmente
come se prendesse tutta la tua vita fino
a quel momento e con il secondo ti trovi
un po come se non avessi quel materiale
la vita ancora la tua ma è tutta nel
primo quindi non ha poi reinvestire la
poi cominciate da un altro lato ma
sempre quella e soprattutto cioè questo
mito che effettivamente viene molto
molto usato a proposito di detti non c'è
quello che dice non sai dove mettere le
mani
in questo caso non so dove mettere le
mani perché so che intascano tenuta eva
non sa dove metterle e quindi abbiamo
capito da dove viene non so dove mettere
mai esistere queste immagini a
chiarissima del foglio bianco
lo scrittore sostanzialmente sta davanti
al foglio bianco per tanto tempo ma io
credo e in parte l'ha detto anche
fabrizio prima anche chi disegna
probabilmente davanti a quel fondo più
bianco anche chi deve prendere una
decisione ha davanti un foglio bianco ed
è un'immagine che che torna utile non lo
puoi dire però viviamo in un'epoca in
cui purtroppo per fortuna non siamo più
identificabili solo ed esclusivamente
con una professione un tempo chi faceva
l'insegnante era insegnante tutta la
vita che faceva al carpentiere
carpentiere tutta la vita medico medico
tutta la vita
noi ci dobbiamo un po sempre reinventare
non è detto che quello che facevamo due
anni fa ancora lo facciamo e quindi
siamo abituati a chiederci mente cosa
fai adesso che è una domanda che
personalmente mi manca sempre un po in
crisi perché sento proprio che la
risposta beh non sto facendo niente
beh sono davanti al foglio bianco non
viene contemplato prima di pubblicare il
primo libro 16 a qualcuno sto scrivendo
prende per pazzo se hai già pubblicato
forse qualcuno tra seconda però
sostanzialmente lo stai facendo niente
non puoi dire a qualcuno sono lì davanti
al foglio bianca in attesa che mi venga
l'idea anche quando c'era il l'idea c'è
questo questo tempo vuoto quando mi
fanno questa domanda è quando comunque
sto molto spesso ovviamente sui social
vedo che c'è ancora forse di più negli
anni precedenti ma tuttora c'è questo
sorta di mantra che ci dice che dobbiamo
andare avanti che dobbiamo muoverci che
dobbiamo far vedere che stiamo facendo
anche anti avanti morti fi cioè quelle
tono se qualcosa non ti sta bene non sei
un albero cambia
muoviti e questo avanti questo muoviti
mi suona un po come almeno fa prima del
mio compagno a proposito della scuola ea
un certo punto mi chiedo ma avanti verso
cosa prima rispetto a cosa e rimango un
po destabilizzata sono appunto
appassionata abbastanza di modi di dire
ce n'è uno e mi piacciono perché secondo
me hanno anche i più banali hanno questa
caratteristica che le cose banali sono
vere no e quindi qualcosa di vero dicono
c'è il detto che può in realtà penso non
è un detto perché è una roba scritta che
non esiste buon vento per il marinaio
che non sa dove andare
siamo tutti i marinai sostanzialmente
dobbiamo occuparci della nostra
direzione
penso che ognuno di noi abbia una sua
direzione parte di questa direzione è
innata parte va costruita per recuperare
entrambe le dimensioni penso che occorra
una cosa che sembra non utile da dire
però davvero credo serva il momento di
pausa di standby di dire ma forse
qualcosa fino adesso è andato storto
prendersi un momento di mobilità anche
come diceva anche prima gaia adesso
viviamo in una fase in cui comunque va
sempre tutto condiviso e le cose ferme
sono è difficile da condividere il
momento di pausa
come fai a condividere quello che non
stai facendo
devi sempre muoverti in qualche modo io
ci credo mi capita spessissimo di vedere
su instagram la gente che s'allena conto
che tallini per fare uno sport no adesso
invece sono gli allenamenti per gli
allenamenti
il mio timore è che questo allenamento
per allenamento questo movimento per il
movimento ci distragga da quello che
deve essere l'obiettivo cioè noi
dobbiamo andare verso qualcosa perché se
andiamo avanti ma non c'è meno chiara la
direzione
rischiamo di trovarci in un posto che
più lontano rispetto a quello che che
volevamo fa paura potrebbe far paura
forse addirittura quelli di qualche anno
più giovane di me capiranno meglio ho
anche un po più grandi ci si aspettava
da noi una sequenza come nelle
pubblicità nasci cresci corre voce
serena si va avanti file superiori fa
l'università trovi il lavoro ti fidanzi
non ti fidanzi fra i finimenti figli vai
avanti non è più così
o perlomeno se ci concentriamo ci
concentriamo troppo sull'idea del
movimento devo far vedere chi mi muovo
devo far vedere che faccio qualcosa
perché ferma non ci si può stare perché
il fermo no lo condividi corre il
rischio di arrivare in un punto e se sei
forte abbastanza un'offerta abbastanza
poi dipende lo diceva anche prima in
parte in parte vasco se ti accorgi che
quella non è la tua direzione occorre
avere il coraggio di fermarsi ancora una
volta invece trovo che il rischio in
questa in questo momento sia ancora una
volta quello di dino stare fermo e non
rimanere davanti a una cosa che crolla
perché se tufino in quel momento è
creduto di voler fare un percorso poi ti
rendi conto che quel percorso
c'è qualcosa che non ti riguarda
comunque non funziona come dovrebbe non
si presti magari fatto tutto quello che
devi fare
sei laureati in tempo e trovato lavoro
interno e felice qualcosa aster 8 vuole
molto coraggio creda rimanere fermi
davanti a quel si può anche di sposare
questa parola fallimento
quando una cosa crolla siamo tentati di
fuggire che immagino proprio anche
durante il terremoto no però davanti a
un disastro
uno si muove non rimane ferma
contemplare pro se ti muovi non dà il
tempo alle cose di riposarsi
io credo che bisogna trovare il coraggio
di dire vabbè aspettiamo che la polvere
si posi assumiamoci il peso di quel
fallimento di quella rottura c'è sempre
quindi un altro detto che dice c'è una
crepa in ogni cosa è da lì che passa
alla luce tra i tanti detti questo qui
in studio mi convince più di tanto però
ci ho riflettuto per ragioni ore anche
anche per il libro e credo che la crepa
in realtà sia la possibilità è una
possibilità c'è una leggenda no dice
comunque giapponesi hanno questo modo di
sistemare le cose che quando un una roba
di coccio si rompe adesso la dico male
ovviamente per sistemarla si usa loro
trovo che sia un occasione in più cioè
cos'è la crepa accusa è una cosa che si
è rotta se non la possibilità di ri
metterla insieme e mettendoci in mezzo
qualcosa che sia una crescita
quando una cosa si rompe abbiamo due
possibilità o per aver ri pharma come
era prima o rimette insieme i pezzi in
un modo che è nuovo
probabilmente anche se non è poi troppo
condivisibile il momento in cui qualcosa
ma in pezzi momento in cui tu va in
pezzi
è quello che ti consente di approfittare
della crepa cioè di prenderti il tuo
margine di crescita a sé due strade o
continui a fare quello che eri prima
oppure ti consente di diventare quello
che potresti quello che sei
forse destinata a diventare in entrambi
i casi credo che serva a convincersi ed
è una cosa che di cui prova convincere
non me lo ripeto anche abbastanza stesso
e che anche nella versione migliore di
noi lo sbaglia è contemplato cioè è
normale che qualcosa si blocchi e
normale che qualcosa non vada secondo i
piani
e normale dire mi sono sbagliato e
soprattutto è normale dire cosa stai
facendo
niente sono stanco sono a pezzi non ce
la faccio a fare niente è condivisibile
anche questo non è stabile ma è
condivisibile e credo che forse ci può
aiutare anche se se riusciamo a dircelo
strusciano a dirlo anche agli altri a
dire a non sentirci costretti a dire beh
sto facendo
no non stai facendo niente gaia diceva
una cosa interessante al portone a
proposito del prodotto l'ansia di
condivisione di far vedere il
procedimento con cui una cosa viene
fatta ci sta facendo dimenticare la
qualità del prodotto cioè ci
dimentichiamo di quello che facciamo
perché siamo ansiosi di condividerlo
il rischio che si corre e non vorrei
essere troppo pessimista e che l'ansia
di condividere ci sta facendo
dimenticare anche quello che siamo non
soltanto quello che facciamo
quindi stiamo calmi se ci sbagliamo ci
fermiamo
predico abbastanza male tra l'altro però
predica in un modo e razzano in un altro
racconterò una storiella che semplifica
un po quello che ho detto fino adesso
perché da una parte dico bisogna avere
coraggio di andare in pezzi di dire ho
sbagliato di dire rimetti pezzi in modo
diverso da come mi aspettavo prima che
nascesse mia figlia ho deciso di di
farle un regalo
ero partita dalla convinzione che il più
bel regalo che puoi fare qualcuna e
riempirlo di bei ricordi ma una bambina
che ancora deve nascere ricordi non è
quindi ho iniziato a raccogliere pezzi
di stoffa a chiederli proprio ai miei
amici pezzi di stoffa importanti per
loro che raccontassero per loro una
storia
e poi io l'avrei messo insieme avrei
cucito insieme questi pezzi e quando lei
sarebbe stata abbastanza grande e aveva
indicato questi pezzi aver raccontato
tutte quelle storie messe insieme è una
leggenda è una cosa che in realtà le
mamme fanno abbastanza spesso nasce da
una leggenda di matrice cinese
credo si cinese cosa è successo
i miei amici sono stati bravissimi verga
ma non mandar giù da anche ogni parte
del mondo pezzi di stoffa avere con
better e bellissime che ho tuttora pezzi
davvero pezzi della loro vita
in realtà io per un po di tempo ho fatto
un po come quelli che si allenano su
instagram
cioè mi muovevo facevo vedere che mi
muovevo raccattava i miei pezzi di
stoffa ma non avevo coraggio di
prenderli
cose che davvero raccontavano una storia
per me cioè non avevo coraggio di dire
beh è ora di prendere atto che questa
cosa è pronta per andare in pezzi e
metterla insieme dentro una cosa che può
diventare quello che deve diventare
quindi magari compravo dei pezzi di
stoffa cincischiava e non ho mai davvero
iniziato a mettere insieme quelli dei
miei amici i miei no ho qui come una
coperta che è la coperta che io non
usava negli ultimi giorni di vita
questa è una delle cose che non ho mai
avuto il coraggio di tagliare pure
questa racconterebbe ad avere una storia
o una gonna di mia nonna che non ho il
coraggio di tagliare
eppure quella racconterebbe una storia o
la maglietta che aveva addosso quando
mia figlia è nata non funziona raggio di
tagliarla poi ho queste scarpe che ci
pensavo comunque anche quando venivo qui
che ho messo in tutte le occasioni
importanti della mia vita me l'ha
regalata credo ormai nove anni fa che
poi le scarpe non si regalano però lui
me l'ha regalato il figlio il mio
compagno si credono nel 2009 quindi 9
anni sono state come in tutti i momenti
più importanti sono logore credo mia
madre vorrebbe buttare via ogni volta
che mi deve del mio compagno anche non
ho mai avuto coraggio di tagliarle però
per l'occasione credo che devo far
vedere che sono una di quelle capaci di
mandare le cose in pezzi mi prendo un
pezzettino e se ce la faccio perché se
fossi allenata come quelli di instagram
probabilmente ci riuscirà ma non essendo
non ci riesco a no ci riesco ci riesco
forse finisco dopo però ecco comunque il
messaggio finirò dopo giuro lo faccio un
po mi viene da piangere però
no non piange
ci devo riuscire insomma la cosa che che
voglia dire questa fermatevi
se sentite il bisogno di fermarvi
sbagliate è normalissimo è previsto e io
me lo dico spesso ultimamente è tutto ok
va bene anche se qualcosa non funziona
come dovrebbe
lasciamo che si rompa troveremo il pezzo
dove metterla e lo legheremo insieme
agli altri pezzi in modo che diventi
quello che deve diventare speriamo
grazie all'altro cruising vastaroli
[Applauso]